Bonjour à vous peuple des internets! Nous sommes aujourd'hui le 5 décembre
il est 6 heures du matin et c'est reparti pour une vidéo en plus.
Au départ je voulais mixer deux vidéos vous savez pour ce cinquième jour du calendrier de l'avant
où j'allais vous parler de mémoire et
également d'un jeu, parce que c'est un peu le principe de vous donner des idées de cadeaux de Noël
parmi les trucs que moi j'aime utiliser, que ce soit des livres, des jeux, des produits vaisselle ou ménager.
On l'a pas fait, mais ça viendra peut être d'ici le 24 décembre.
Et là, je me suis aperçu que sur l'un des jeux dont je voulais vous parler aujourd'hui il y avait beaucoup de choses à dire
et beaucoup de trucs funs par définition. En fait je vais vous parler de deux jeux. Non pas d'un madame,
non pas de deux, mais de 2 en fait si.
Le jeu s'appelle "Ki a fait ça ?"
"Ki a fait ça ?" de topito, c'est édité chez First,
c'est évidemment le même éditeur que moi y a pas de problème mais ça n'empêche que c'est pas un placement de produit
puisque c'est un jeu que j'ai acquis par moi-même et auquel j'ai commencé à jouer.
Non je le dis parce que si on le dit pas après les gens ils font : "oh, c'est un placement produit"
alors que, quand c'est un placement de produit, on le dit pas, on dit pas que c'est pas un placement.
Donc dans ce jeu il y a quasiment pas de règles, c'est on prend une carte et on pose au joueur de gauche et
on tourne comme ça et si la personne a réussi
à répondre à la question, elle marque le point et ce n'est que des qui a dit ça ou qui a fait ça ou
quelques cartes bonus qui apportent un petit peu de peps au jeu, ça c'est par exemple, tu pioches cette carte bonus. Carte
"Non mais c'est pas vrai c'est dégueulasse"
Donc il se passe quoi ?
"Je perds tous mes points parce que la vie est une p*te, oui"
C'est vraiment marqué ça comme ça. Donc vous voyez un petit peu le ton du jeu
et les "qui a fait ça" et "qui a dit ça" sont que des choses réelles qui se sont vraiment passées. Je vous propose dans cette
vidéo de vous en lire quelques-unes.
"Qui a fait ça":
s'appelait comme une couleur:
Julien Clerc, un obscur chanteur, Michel Blanc, qui a des valeurs Edouard Baer, je suis enrhubé,
Benjamin Biolay, et décidément ce rhume ne s'arrange pas.
C'est très facile, c'est la réponse 2 Michel Blanc, du coup je vais essayer d'en trouver un autre. Mais vous voyez un petit peu l'idée.
"Qui a fait ça": découper son père pour en faire un meuble télé,
donc ça s'est vraiment passé,
quatre propositions
néanmoins:
1) un jeune homme après une légère dispute
2) une jeune femme complètement dans l'ivresse
3) une prof d'arts plastiques qui n'avait plus de papier pour son atelier de découpage
4) Luke Skywalker
Je vous laisse réfléchir et faire votre proposition dans l'espace commentaires prévu à cet effet, ou peut-être inventer une
cinquième proposition je pense que ça fait parti des règles du jeu, pourquoi pas.
Et la réponse était la réponse une: un jeune homme après une légère dispute avec son père
il l'a donc découpé et il en a fait un meuble télé.
Histoire vraie !
Parce que quand c'est une histoire vraie il y a toujours le petit logo histoire vraie.
"Qui a fait ça":
Je n'étais pas tombé sur celle-ci encore.
se masturber à chaque passage du tracteur:
1) Karine Lemarchand, à qui "L'amour est dans le pré" tape un peu sur le système
2) José Bové, on aurait dû se méfier de la moustache depuis le début
3) Un adolescent de Bourg-En-Bresse qui vit assez mal sa poussée d'hormones
ou 4) un gentil monsieur dans une vidéo star de Jacky et Michel.
Alors, d'après vous, Karine le Marchand,
José Bové, un adolescent de Bourg-en-Bresse ou un gentil môssieur sur Jackie et Michel.
Et la bonne réponse est la réponse, je veux vous entendre dans les commentaires, "oui!"
la réponse 3:
un jeune de Bourg-en-Bresse
qui vivait très mal sa poussée d'hormones.
Est-ce que j'en fais d'autres ? Allez oui j'en fais encore
quelques-unes. Ah j'ai pas trop fait de "Qui a dit ça" par contre.
"Qui a dit ça", il est trop facile celui-là mais comme les propositions son drôles je vais quand même vous le lire.
"Qui a dit ça": "un grand pouvoir implique de grandes responsabilités"
Réponse 1: Dumbledore qui aime bien faire chier le monde avec ses grands principes à la con
Réponse 2: Laurent Voulzy dans le pouvoir des fleurs
Réponse 3: Serge Rouvière, après sa victoire au championnat de pétanque de 1977 à Edoum
4: un certain Benjamin Parker à son neveu ingrat boutonneux et récemment piqué par une vilaine araignée. La réponse est, bien sûr,
Ben Parker à son neveu
Peter Parker alias spider man.
Je me rends compte, au fur et à mesure que je vous en lis, que cette vidéo va être démonétisée à
6h01 du matin, ce que je lis littéralement c'est quand même marqueé
"Qui a dit ça", tiens celui-là, "la politique, c'est comme de l'andouillette ça doit sentir un peu la merde mais pas trop"
J'ai le souvenir d'une andouillette que j'avais mangé à Angers avec VodK et Amixem l'autre jour,
et bien c'est vrai,
ça sent un peu.
Alors réponse 1: André Santini entre deux digestifs,
Edouard Herriot entre deux digestifs aussi, mon oncle qui
compare vraiment tout à de la bouffe,
ou mon boucher entre deux blagues de cul.
La réponse est,
ça aurait pu être mon boucher mais non, c'est Edouard Herriot après 2 digestifs aussi. Et on terminera
sur le jeu, pas la vidéo - Reste là jusqu'au bout ! - avec un "Qui a fait ça" un peu énorme "Qui a fait ça", ça me
fait penser un peu aux jeux qu'on fait des fois en live les black stories, "Qui a fait ça": se suicider pour l'honneur,
j'ai bien dit se suicider pour l'honneur, réponse 1: Jerôme Cardan l'histoire de mourir le jour qu'il avait annoncé 15 ans avant,
réponse 2: Maurice Ravel histoire de mourir en écoutant son boléro
Réponse 3: René Descartes histoire de mourir avant de terminer un bouquin trop nul, réponse 4: Harry Houdini
histoire de ne pas avoir à faire un tour de magie quI allait foirer. Et la réponse est
la réponse 1: Jerôme Cardan
avait annoncé qu'il mourrait tel jour, telle date,
quinze ans auparavant.
Et par ego, par orgueil, ce jour-là, comme il n'était pas malade, etc contrairement à tout ce qu'il avait prévu, il s'est suicidé
pour qu'on puisse pas lui dire le lendemain "Ah tu vois! Tu t'étais trompé.
Ça c'est ce qui s'appelle, ne pas assumer avoir tort mais quand même avoir des cojones pour faire ça.
Voilà c'est l'idée du jeu vous avez vu c'est très simple c'est
ça se joue mais ça se lit aussi c'est assez rigolo à lire du coup on peut aussi en faire une vidéo dessus
qui sera rempli de mots un petit peu olé olé dirons nous
Ce jeu il me fait clairement penser un autre jeu dont je n'ai jamais parlé sur la chaîne parce que j'avais déjà pas mal de
youtubeurs qui avaient fait des vidéos dessus des deux dernières années si vous êtes passé à côté c'est blanc manger coco
c'est un jeu qui n'a pas de sens c'est super drôle je vous le recommande c'est vraiment pour adultes et adultes responsables
parce que ça va créer des phrase humoristique parfois qui sont hyper trash hyper violente
l'idée c'est que d'un côté il ya des cartes avec des trous il faut compléter
les joueurs ont toujours onze cartes dans les mains avec des mots permettant de compléter ces trous et à chaque carte retourner chacun fait
sa proposition pour compléter et un juge complètement partiale
avec un avis complètement subjectif va dire lequel des deux est le plus drôle mais ça peut donner par exemple ici j'ai un vide
avec ça nous a fait un bien fou encore mieux qu'à thalasso et bien ça pourrait donner
louer ses enfants ça nous a fait un bien fou mieux encore qu'une thalasso ou ça pourrait donner
18 heures d'histoire du pastis ça nous fait un bien fou
mieux encore que la thalasso
vous avez compris le principe s'appelle blanc-manger coco c'est deux étudiants qu'avait fait ça. ça fait un carton c'est très très drôle
y'a rien à perdre y'a rien à gagner dans ce jeu à part vraiment se marrer en fin de soirée
ou en début de soirée ou en milieu de soirée voilà alors comme d'habitude vous avez
les liens vers ses jeux dans la description de la vidéo et
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air à la vidéo si elle vous a plu et de vous abonner si c'est pas encore fait vous avez
également toutes les informations
pour les questions que vous pouvez vous poser dans la description j'ai l'impression d’être Julien Lepers à l'époque où il présentait
question pour un champion à demain matin 6h ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais